hi
on the
on the films I've been talking about Out
of Body Experience
but
I don't really know what that means
because what I've been talking about is
an inner body experience
I think when you say the outer body
experience when we're unsure of
what we're saying because it's
it's something that we we can't equate
to we it's not something that happens is
it
I'm sure we all touch from time to time
a Deja Vu moment
and I'd put it more in the deja vu
category
but what about if you had a Deja Vu
moment that lasted and lasted and lasted
and those who've seen um
grow up the film Groundhog Day
a very unusual film but
makes you makes you think about how each
day
he knew what was coming in the end so he
could replan what he could do with it
and um
it's a little bit like
so far I've been talking about
out-of-body experiences and warm air
becoming
part of part of you and being in the
theater and
sensing them
no one else was there and I was immersed
in a warmth for love that
you just don't feel it in this normal
world you don't feel it in this um
human environment
perhaps it gets tangled up with all the
the problems that people as humans have
anybody who discovers nature to adapt
where nature
is so important because they realize
that they are part of nature
no more no less
and the less you disturb nature
the more it will benefit you
if you if you're kind
to the planet then I believe the planet
will be kind to you
yes people say to me um oh but what
about the past wrongs that you've done
perhaps that's why you're being punished
now with
you know
arthritis and illness and
you know all the things that people get
not necessarily when they're old
perhaps their past things that you're
now being having to pay for
well I suppose we could always say that
couldn't we but all I know is
the kind we are
to our planet as an individual
the less
it appears to harm us well that's my
experience and I can only tell you about
my experience of course I can't tell you
about your experience can I or anyone
else's
I don't know what's inside your head I
don't know what makes you tick
I don't even know if I know what makes
myself tick to you
anyhow I'd like to talk about
enlightenment
again
I
was talking to the
people on on my Patron site
about what it was like to be enlightened
and
for two I said at the time when when it
came over me my my greatest
Enlightenment was on a trip
following mother mirror in Frankfurt in
Germany where she's outside Frankfurt
that's where you fly into
and they hide this out of Body
Experience again what was inner my inner
body over two weeks the most unusual
thing happened
I could hear people talking across the
street even if they were whispering I
could still hear them I don't know how
night was as by his day
so I didn't need a torch
yes the Stars might have been out I
don't know but there didn't seem to be
any change in the density of light to my
eyes
perhaps I'd gone mad who knows for two
weeks
a woman had two children and I was
walking along a path in Cambridge
and she scolded one of them
and it was as if my body had been
scolded and oh it really her nine of
physical sense but my emotions
were really
hurt with this
I realized then
that my senses that I never had on such
a high
endearment before
working overtime
I think I felt at the time as if I
couldn't stop smiling it was as if there
was a love pouring out of me
was it Tony's love I don't know I I
really don't know what it was was
it was a love greater than what a human
being can give
to another human being but the love was
so great pouring out
that it was almost pouring out to
everyone and everything every item
it was a
it was a great feeling
I couldn't really talk to people about
it at the time because I didn't know
what was happening to me
was I going mad I don't know it's just
time wasn't an essence
I I missed a plane
a train I missed all sorts of things
because time seems to not matter
and when I looked at my watch
I don't know even if I was seeing time
all I know was when I arrived at the
different destinations
I'll just hold the plane had gone
then I got on the wrong train but it
didn't matter nothing seemed to matter
so for two weeks I was in a complete
confused state but happy
but I watched the world humans
within this period of those around me
because that's all you can do
I went to Cambridge City I live in the
country so it was an act that I had to I
still run my business going to the city
and act normal
so I don't know whether I was acting
normal to others but I was trying to or
say fake being normal and trying to
suppress the joy but not wishing to
suppress the joy that I had Within Me
but what I had time to do is I had time
to think
well look you're you've got a business
you're running
you've got staff that rely on you
I do martial arts I do yoga
um
I have a family to bring help
and I
and it came to me that
to
you've got to make a decision
Tony I thought
the
the world you're living in mentally
and physically really
at this moment in these two weeks
would it fit into
the world that you had two weeks before
he was enlightened
and I realized then that
I couldn't stack or keep I couldn't keep
the world of Enlightenment within me
because I didn't know that place
I don't have any friends in that place
I don't have a family in that place
my work has to be quick thinking my
business that'd be quick thinking I
employed staff who would have problems
and you had to
sort to sort that out
I had
turnover millions of pounds that had to
be considered it's no good being what I
call flake headed or have a Airhead on
you when you have to make big decisions
so I decided then that the world I knew
was the one this lifetime I must stay in
because the enlightened world
I wasn't ready for I wasn't equipped for
I think if you are Buddhist my uncle or
anybody in religion that starts off
young enough and you hone yourself to
that way of thinking to that
lifetime of understanding
make it your life's work then I think
you can slowly prepare yourself
and then if you do become lucky enough
to be enlightened
then you can adapt to it
I couldn't adapt to it
after making
a lifetime of friends work business
family life
there was too many obstacles in my way
to just would say
go and sell the mountain and be happy
ever after
I couldn't just dress up in a
a monk's robe or simple clothes a
blanket
and become a
a good person to help those in need
the transformation was far too great
and and then to me an impossible bridge
to
uh
just walk across
however going back
um to my Aikido world and my yoga
meditation to achieve life
because I had those within the
or say
the what normal work is my life I could
take an element
of the understanding well-being
enlightened I could take this element
back with me
so
as I said in the other film about the
cork draining me
this time it didn't drain
the warmth kept inside me
and
fantastic wood as we
say in England
hoping that that will help us it stayed
with me
and
so when I do my Aikido now
or anything
um
I do it with the joy and the love and
the warmth that I got from
that experience
I also felt great comfort in knowing
that my master cytosensi
he he taught me well because he gave me
the technical apparatus
to allow the techniques to work
so if you've got the technical path
correct
blend it with a good understanding
and the giving of love
to everything in the universe
and to not wish harm to others you know
don't get me wrong I'm a human being
I'm judgmental and I try not to be and I
have many bad faults
I'm not going to be the best aikidoka in
the world far from it
there's some superb people out there I'm
not one of them
I would have liked to have been but I'm
not
but I'm just telling you the experience
that I am grateful that I received to me
I bought it the enlightenment part back
into a human being's life
so when I do now move on the map or
carry out my aikeno techniques
I'm allowed to do it with the love and
joy
of not clashing
because you see if you have it correctly
to me
you cannot clash with something
because the pathway is always
Harmony
and and and you find that you can't
Clash
with something if you have no desire to
clash with it but you're happy to go
with it if the weather Bands then bend
and enjoy the flow
try not to clash with anything
and
I hope that we will have a
smoother path from the rest of our life
I hope this has made some sense if not I
hope it's been worth just listening
to my story
and I hope that all of you
find this path of
just
not harming the planet any more than you
have to
and hopefully it will still be here when
we're not
thank you for listening